>>Female Presenter: Welcome everybody to this
discussion of "Oakland in Popular Memory."
I'm very proud to introduce my friend Matt
Werner today.
And it's incredibly interesting.
I've read it and it's over here and you should
definitely pick up a copy.
His incredibly interesting book.
The image of Oakland, California has been
tainted in the mainstream media with salacious
news reports focusing on street violence,
shootings, gangs, and riots.
These reports, along with assumptions and
stereotypes, feed the fabricated image that
outsiders have of the city.
In "Oakland in Popular Memory," interviews
with 12 cutting-edge musicians from Oakland
and beyond, Oakland native and former host
of the award-winning radio show on Fresh Air:
The Alternative.
Matt Werner introduces a different narrative
representing a collection of his best interviews
with leading artists from Oakland and artists
who've influenced musicians from Oakland.
In the spirit of Studs Terkel, Werner conducted
long form interviews from 2008 to 2012, which
cover the 2008 election of President Obama,
the shooting of Oscar Grant, and the Occupy
Oakland protests.
Werner spoke with artists at length discussing
topics like race relations in Oakland in the
post-Oscar Grant era, post literary theory,
and the changing landscape of the music industry
during the Digital Revolution.
And with that, and I'm sure you'll see significantly
more, I'm happy to introduce Matt Werner.
[applause]
>>Matt: Thank you.
[pause]
Little did I know, when I started the book,
"Oakland in Popular Memory" in June 2011,
that I would get tear-gassed during my research.
Little did I know when I started researching
Oakland's history, looking into ways to apply
it to current events that it would set me
on a collision course with Occupy Oakland.
[pause]
I know that having grown up in Oakland, California,
that it's several cities in one.
But over the past year, I've seen that Oakland
is a never-ending conversation and it's greatly
misunderstood by the outside media.
Take, for example, yesterday's New York Times
Magazine article titled "Oakland, the Last
Refuge of Radical America."
It calls Oakland quote "a kind of Amish village
for retro-radicals."
And it portrays Oakland as overrun with anarchists,
communists, ineffective city leadership, and
aging radicals.
Essentially, it portrays Oakland as a retirement
home for radicals.
Last Friday, I ran into Boots Riley of The
Coup at the First Friday Art Murmur.
And I asked what he thought of this article
which profiled him so prominently in yesterday's
New York Times.
And he replied quote that "Oakland isn't the
end of an old radical movement.
It's the beginning of a new one."
And I thought that was a interesting point
that he made.
However, the Oakland that I've grown up and
experienced is one that, it's quite different
from that.
And it's this Oakland that I've grown up in
is one that I wanna share with you guys today.
So, I interviewed 12 artists and musicians
from Oakland and those who've had a big impact
on Oakland artists.
And I collected those interviews into the
book "Oakland in Popular Memory."
And so, the structure of my talk is as follows.
I'll read the afterword first and then the
introduction.
The second part of the talk, I'll talk about
the design, printing, and the book binding.
And then, thirdly, I'll talk about how I actually
did the interviews themselves on the radio
show I had in grad school.
And then at the end, I'll open it up for questions.
[pause]
So, I'll begin reading the afterword, which
is titled "Gertrude Stein's Oakland."
And I initially wrote this as a blog post
for the Google Books blog on February 3rd
this year, which was Gertrude Stein's birthday.
[reads from book]
"Ever since Gertrude Stein wrote of Oakland,
quote, 'there is no there there,' people have
used this quote to condemn the city.
But taking a closer look at the quote and
the context in which it was written, we can
see it is an expression of 'painful nostalgia'
and not of disdain or insult to Oakland.
Let's take a closer look at this famous quote
and how it relates to the artists interviewed
in this book, putting a new 'there' in Oakland.
The quote comes from page 298 of Stein's 'Everybody's
Autobiography,' published in 1937.
The full quote is 'what was the use of my
having come from Oakland.
It was not natural to have come from there
yes write about it if I like or anything if
I like but not there, there is no there there.'
Stein's family moved to Oakland in 1880, when
she was six.
Her family lived in a home near today's 13th
Avenue and East 25th Street.
She lived in Oakland until 1891, and left
at age 17 for Baltimore, after her parents
passed away.
Oakland was a much smaller town back then,
with a population of just under 35 thousand
in 1880.
Nearly 45 years later, Stein returned to Oakland
on a lecture tour in 1935.
By that time, the city had grown nearly ten
times to over 300 thousand residents.
When she tried to find her childhood home,
it was no longer there.
When she published 'Everybody's Autobiography'
two years later, saying there was 'no there
there,' it was written to reflect a painful
nostalgia about her home being gone and the
land around it being completely changed.
The house where she grew up was on a sprawling
ten-acre plot surrounded by orchards and farms.
By 1935, it had been replaced by dozens of
houses.
Oakland held a special significance to her,
and on her return, she found that Oakland
had urbanized and changed from the pastoral
place she remembered.
Gertrude Stein writes in her autobiographical
novel, 'The Making of Americans,' about her
childhood in Oakland, where a child 'could
have all anybody could want of joyous sweating,
of rain and wind, of hunting, of cows and
dogs and horses, of chopping wood, of making
hay, of dreaming, of lying in a hollow all
warm with the sun shining while the wind was
howling.'
Returning to her home decades later to find
it gone and to find Oakland no longer a place
'of chopping wood, of making hay' struck her,
and she wrote her famous 'no there there'
quote in response.
This makes me wonder if one of the artists
interviewed in this book were to return to
Oakland 40 years from now, would they recognize
the city?
One theme in some of the interviews was a
notion of disenfranchisement similar to what
Stein experienced by returning to a changed
city.
People are getting pushed out of Oakland at
an alarming rate.
African Americans made up nearly 50 percent
of the city when I was born in 1984, and that
number has dropped to only 27 percent today.
There were 33 thousand fewer African Americans
living in Oakland in 2010 than there were
in 2000.
Like Stein returning to Oakland to find it
completely changed, would an artist interviewed
in this book experience a similar feeling
returning to Oakland 40 years from now?
When researching Gertrude Stein at the Oakland
History Room, the literary portrait files
had photos of Jack London, a contemporary
of Stein's, who also grew up in Oakland.
The file included other famous authors who
visited Oakland in the late 1800s, including
Mark Twain, Robert Louis Stevenson, and John
Muir.
Despite the misinterpretation of Stein's quote,
there had always been a 'there' in Oakland.
Oakland has been blessed with several waves
of artistic movements, stretching back to
these authors.
And in interviewing innovative artists and
writers in Oakland today for this book, I've
seen first-hand that now, more than ever,
there is a 'there' in Oakland."
[pause]
So that's the afterword that I conclude the
book with.
And I was very happy.
The Huffington Post recently ran that.
And then, next, I'm gonna read the introduction,
which is a little bit more polemical.
It's called "In Defense of Oakland."
And this piece, it's a little bit longer just
to give you guys fair warning.
I think it's around 15 minutes.
So, just give you guys heads up.
[reads from book]
"When I was an undergraduate at UC Berkeley,
I remember talking with a sorority girl at
a party about where we grew up.
She was from Orange County.
I replied I was born in Oakland, and I grew
up in Alameda, Oakland, Berkeley, and Palo
Alto.
She stared at me in disbelief.
One word stood out to her.
'Oakland?
Oh, we don't go into Oakland.'
When I prodded her some more, she said that
Oakland was so violent, and that there were
so many murders, and that her parents warned
her never to go into Oakland.
Eventually, I got her to admit that she goes
Zachary's Pizza only a couple of miles south
of UC Berkeley and to Fentons Ice Creamery.
But she insisted that she didn't venture any
further into Oakland than Fentons.
It was clear that the mere mention of 'Oakland"
triggered something of a fear response in
her.
Her use of the word 'into' was also very telling.
In a sense, that one little word reflected
not only her fear but many people's ambivalence
toward Oakland as well.
It was as if the locales of Zachary's and
Fentons--upper middle class neighborhoods--were
not part of Oakland but extensions of Berkeley,
and that the idea of venturing any farther
'into' Oakland was unfathomable.
Fear is driven by the unknown, and the fact
that she wouldn't go any further into Oakland
meant that she would remain fearful of Oakland--especially
if her only exposure to the city was through
the media's violence-centered and racially-charged
depiction of it.
By not stepping outside her comfort zone to
see Oakland for what it really was, she would
continue to harbor these thoughts about my
place of birth.
This encounter has stayed with me because,
for the first time, I began to consider Oakland
through the eyes of an 'outsider.'
This encounter is representative of the many
I've had since, and it is these misconceptions
that motivated me to offer a different narrative
of Oakland.
The Oakland I've grown up in has its challenges
like any major city, but what stands out to
me is the cultural renaissance happening in
Oakland today.
I've been privileged to have a front-row seat
to witness what's been happening in Oakland,
and this book is a collection of interviews
with those people who know it best--musicians
and writers from Oakland who are shaping its
art scene.
Wanting to understand the outsider's perspective
of Oakland, I wondered, why do even reputable
outlets like the Discovery Channel air sensationalist
programming about Oakland?
They have two shows called 'Gang Wars: Oakland'
and 'Gang Wars II: Oakland,' [laughter] which
follow the Oakland Gang Task Force.
So by a show of hands, I was wondering, are
any of you guys familiar with these shows?
Have you seen the Gang Wars programming about
Oakland?
OK so, just a couple people, so all cue you
guys in.
The first episode begins with a deep voice-over
saying, 'Oakland, California home to some
of the most violent gangs in America.
Here, almost ten thousand gang members rule
with deadly force, recruiting teens, running
drugs, selling guns, and murdering on a whim.
Now, an elite police unit made up of just
eight men fights to bring justice to the streets,
and the top gang lords are arrested to make
Oakland safe again, but something has gone
terribly wrong.'
The voice-over continues, painting a grim
portrait of Oakland, calling it, quote, 'ground
zero in a new American war.
Violent street gangs fight over drug turf,
and the battle is only escalating.'
Comparisons to Iraq add to the already sensational
tone, giving viewers the impression that just
below the surface, Oakland is fomenting with
such violence, that at any moment all hell
will break loose.
With this much negative press, it's no wonder
people are afraid to go into Oakland.
Given the presuppositions and stereotypes
that result from such portrayals, it's hard
for visitors to experience the reality of
what is presented before them because it clashes
with the narrative they've internalized from
countless news reports.
People consuming this type of media go to
Oakland expecting to find drive-by shootings,
roving gangs toting AK-47s, as well as pimps,
prostitutes, and race riots.
However, people visiting Oakland are often
surprised when they don't see this, but instead
find several avant-garde movements in art,
music, fashion, urban farming, and local food.
Chinaka Hodge, an Oakland writer, whom I was
fortunate to interview for this collection,
writes about the perceptions of Oakland in
her blog."
And then, I wanna give a little extended quote
from Chinaka here.
" 'I lived on the East Coast for a few years.
Tell a New Yorker you're from Cali, and they'll
assume, eight times out of ten, that you're
from Los Angeles.
I live in LA now.
Tell the average Angeleno that you're from
up North, they assume San Francisco.
Oakland is constantly upstaged, asterisked,
and misunderstood.
In my travels, I still field questions about
the 1996 Ebonics debate, I talk about a hoop
squad that is more than Latrell's hands around
someone's neck, I remind that we are more
than the riots that followed the Raiders'
loss at the 2003 Super Bowl.'
Hodge continues, setting the record straight
about what Oakland is and what the city does
best.
[beeping on screen] 'In short, Oakland is
proud because no one else will be proud for
us.
We exercise a rich cultural legacy, a policy
for introspection and a knack for finding
the next.
The town is a study in surprise, in artistic
innovation, in movements foreign to the rest
of the planet.
We are the birthplace of leather jackets rocked
with berets at free breakfast, where Skyline
High School taught Tom Hanks to act, the original
terminal for all Pullman Porter activity,
where Walt Disney visited a theme park near
a lake and began drafting ideas for Disneyland.
Here, we make ideas that power the world.
We do what no one else does, and we do it
well.'
Hodge's poetic description giving snapshots
of various periods of Oakland's history captures
Oakland's free-spirited character that is
at once tough, artistic, and even sensitive--a
character often misunderstood.
But Oakland is unapologetic.
After all, it knows who it is--a strong city,
that's gracious and accepting of people from
all economic and cultural backgrounds.
Oakland residents are resilient, free-spirited,
and confident, qualities which keep the city
at the cutting edge and help it forge trends
in fashion, music, dance, or as Hodge puts
it, making 'ideas that power the world.'
These ideas are indeed powerful as they go
beyond individual expression and often speak
to the collective soul of a generation or
a group of people.
Oakland often mediates the production of art,
language, and cultural innovation for the
US and it has regularly produced some of the
country's top talent."
So, I'm skipping ahead to the final section
of the introduction.
It's called "Oakland: The secret is out."
[reads from book]
"Ishmael Reed wrote in 'Oakland Rhapsody:
The Secret Soul of an American Downtown' in
1995, that Oakland is America's best kept
secret.
Well, the secret is out.
And the media is starting to take notice.
The New York Times ranked Oakland as one of
the top five places to visit in the world
in 2012.
The New York Times Travel Section gives credit
to Oakland native chef James Syhabout, but
it also points that Oakland is now worth visiting
because famous San Francisco chefs have decided
to set up shop in Oakland.
But it's not only such entrepreneurial transplants
that makes Oakland worth visiting.
Those in the know would say the media's recognition
of Oakland's thriving cultural realm was long
overdue, especially given the city's growth
spurt in the art, music, fashion, and literary
scenes in the last decade.
In the last few years alone, over a dozen
new art galleries have popped up in Oakland's
Northgate-Waverly district, previously known
for its auto repair shops and warehouses.
Such a Renaissance no doubt draws inspiration
from Oakland's rich history as a cultural
destination in the late 19th century, hosting
the likes of Gertrude Stein, Jack London,
Mark Twain, Robert Louis Stevenson, and John
Muir, to name a few.
More recently, Oakland gave birth to the Hyphy
Movement, the Scraper Bike movement, and turf
dancing, while Mac Dre, E-40, and Keak da
Sneak invented much of the hip-hop language
used internationally today.
Several local news sources have sprung up
in recent years to document this renaissance
in art collectives, local food movement, urban
farming, and music, including Oakland Local,
Oakland North, Bay Citizen, Oakland Seen,
Thizzler, and 38th Notes.
The Bay Area's indie and underground scenes
are constantly studies in surprise.
They've historically been engines of innovation,
creating new musical styles and language.
What's happening on the ground today in the
Bay may take months or even years to become
mainstream.
Novelist William Gibson said 'The future is
already here--it's just not very evenly distributed.'
In the Bay Area, the future in music and language
is already here.
Each artist I interviewed is innovating in
his or her own way.
You can listen to the future of music through
these artists.
Oakland is a never ending conversation.
In this book, I didn't have to set out to
curate viewpoints or quell perspectives that
differ with my own.
And I don't pretend to have the city wrapped
up.
Studying Oakland's history and reading books
like 'No There There: Race, Class, and Political
Community in Oakland' by Chris Rhomberg and
'American Babylon: Race and the Struggle for
Postwar Oakland' by Robert Self, I've found
more paradoxes about my hometown than I can
reconcile.
These artists who voice the paradoxes of urban
America give us a unique lens through which
to view Oakland.
These twelve established and up-and-coming
artists give perspectives on Oakland different
from the usual media narrative about the city.
What I admire about these artists is how they've
kept their authenticity as they've grown in
their music and how they champion the Oakland
quality of having a knack for finding the
next.
And as for the sorority girl at the beginning,
I hope she visited Oakland while she was at
UC Berkeley.
If not, she sure missed out on a lot."
[pause]
So that was the end of the introduction.
So, now for the second phase of the talk,
I'll walk you guys through how I actually
put the book together 'cause it's a fairly
non-conventional process I used.
So, I have some photos here on Google+ which
I'll flip through.
[pause]
So, I ended up.
So basically, to give context, my cousin is
a printer in Sacramento and my uncle is a
book binder in Berkeley.
So I used the family resources and I printed
and then hand bound all the books myself,
with help of family.
So, this is my cousin Sean right here.
He's a master printer.
And we actually used laser printers 'cause
he has about a hundred of them in his warehouse.
And so, this is him getting a duplexer unit
ready.
And then this is example of basically how
I printed out pages.
And then there's Sean.
He's, let's see.
I have that he's checking the toner density.
And what was interesting is as being the author,
I did the design, layout, copy editing, proofreading,
and I mean, I did have a group of friends
helping me out.
But it's very interesting then printing and
then binding your own work 'cause not too
many authors do that today.
But then, having all of this full creative
control over the book itself, I was able to
do some special things with it.
Oh, yep.
So these are the printers.
So, it's good to have a cousin when you're
a writer with these kind of printers.
And for those of you who were at my Tech Talk
last year about my first book, I used pretty
much the same exact process from printing
the first book as with the second one.
So, I ended up using Strathmore, 100 percent
cotton paper which is perhaps the most expensive
paper you can use because it's archival quality.
And the reason I chose this is because when
I was working at UC Berkeley as an undergrad,
I got to work in their Bancroft Library, which
is their special archiving collections.
And if we wanted something to last for a long
time, we would print it out on 100 percent
cotton paper because it'll last for hundreds
of years.
So, I ended up going upscale with that one
area.
And then also, why I chose this paper is that
I used to intern and volunteer at McSweeney's
Publishing in San Francisco.
So I was there for about five years and I
got to work closely with the author Dave Eggers.
And on a number of the projects, they're very
unique and special binding.
And they use very high-quality paper.
And the reason for doing this is that in this
digital age, a lot of the large publishers
now, they're trying to cut costs and bend
corners any way possible.
So, a lot of them now are printing on newsprint
essentially.
They're having the books printed in China
very cheaply and then shipped here in bulk.
But if you guys have ever been to like, Wal-Mart
or Target and you go to the book section and
you pick up the book, it doesn't really feel
like a quality object.
Whereas in this digital age, I feel it's very
interesting being a Google employee stepping
back and saying, "Well, there is validity
to e-readers, but I don't think the printed
book in its form is gonna go out of fashion."
And so, as a counter argument, I've been going
in the opposite direction of showing the staying
power of the book as a physical object and
really making something beautiful and it be
coveted.
So, that's a long explanation of why I chose
the paper I did.
And then, so here we are now.
This is my uncle's binding shop in Berkeley.
And so, that's my sister, Kelly, and friend,
Sean.
And basically, he sells these book binding
machines.
And then this is also a foil printer.
So usually, to be able to get foil on a book
cover, you need to get a stamp dye, but those
are, it's very expensive.
And I wanna keep this low budget.
So, it just happens that my uncle has these
printers that can print in gold and silver
foil.
So, I ended up choosing silver with the black
background to get the Oakland Raiders look--the
silver and black.
[laughter] So, there's Sean doing quality
control.
So basically I printed everything out on eight
and a half by eleven paper.
And then we used this paper trimmer.
We cut the manuscript in half.
And then we would fold the halves back in
to make a book bundle.
And we put the two covers on both sides.
And then, there's my brother.
So basically, we would put this binding strip
in this machine and it would heat press the
binding strip onto the edges of the paper.
And then once the glue that was super heated
then cooled, then the book was ready to go.
So basically, I got all my extended family
to come out and help out.
So, I ended up making three versions of the
book.
On the left, you have the green and yellow,
which is the Oakland A's version.
In the center is the silver and black, the
Oakland Raiders version, which was the one
that I mass produced.
And then I had the blue and gold version,
which is for Golden State Warriors, or UC
Berkeley 'cause I'm a big Cal fan.
[pause]
And then, by making these one at a time by
hand, we could just do any kind of custom
cover combination we wanted, then be experimental
and creative with it.
Whereas, had I sent it off to a large printer,
I wouldn't have been able to have this artistic
control.
And then this is my uncle Dick, Jim Kelly.
It was great to have him on-site 'cause he
helped create and invent these machines.
And so, if we ran into any problems, he was
there to help troubleshoot.
And then there's my dad binding the books.
And then you can see the black binding strips
there that he inserts.
And that machine in front of the binder is
actually a spine printer.
And that's what we used to print the spine.
[pause]
And there's the book being super heated in
the press.
And then there's my mom collating the manuscripts
into a book.
So, I really got the whole family out there.
[pause]
OK.
So that's the collection, a little bit of
the book process.
And then next, I want to, I'm going to bring
up, talk a little bit about the artist interviews
that I did.
And then after that, I'll open it up for questions.
OK.
So, this is Chinaka Hodge, who is the first
interview in the book.
I had a former classmate of mine from the
University of Edinburgh, where I went to grad
school.
She's a very good portrait artist, Laura Tomlinson.
And I asked her to draw portraits of the twelve
people I interviewed.
And I thought she did an excellent job just
using pencil on plain paper.
And so, I had her draw the various portraits.
This is Rafael Casal, who''s from Berkeley.
And how I chose the various people interviewed
was I had this college radio show in Scotland,
but out there people were very interested
in what was happening in the West Coast hip-hop
scene and the indie rock scene out here.
And so, I started out interviewing friends
of mine and friends of friends who I had grown
up with through Youth Speaks doing poetry
slams here in the Bay area.
And so, Rafael Casal is, he's a real well-known
in the poetry slam and spoken word circuit.
And he's just now emerging as a talent in
the hip-hop arena.
[pause]
And here's Dahlak Brathwaite.
He's from Sacramento.
[pause]
So, this is Dave Smallen.
We went to high school together at Bishop
O'Dowd in East Oakland.
And he actually designed the cover of the
book.
And so, for the cover, I told him I wanted
something that says "Oakland."
And so we have Oakland in the block letters.
And then we have the Oakland Tribune tower
with an oak tree behind it.
And he actually created a linoleum block print.
So he carved a piece of linoleum and then
put ink on it and then pressed a paper on
it.
And then I have the original that I based
the cover off of right over there.
And then basically, I scanned his print and
then yeah, I made the foil version that you
see on the final cover.
So, this is George Watsky.
He was the first interview I did back in 2008
because he was very obscure at that time.
And I knew I could get him 'cause he was a
friend of mine growing up from the poetry
slam circuit.
But it just happens that, just in the last
year, he's gained a lot of notoriety because
of a viral video he made on YouTube called
"Pale Kid Raps Fast," which has over ten million
views.
And he got to go on the Ellen DeGeneres show
twice this year to showcase his fast rapping
style.
But I chose a picture of him where it showed
his swagger and personality.
[pause]
And then this is Ise Lyfe.
The interview I did with him was one of the
most provocative ones because it really made
me question some of the assumptions and stereotypes
that I had of living in Oakland.
And he really brought a much needed perspective.
We discuss quite a bit around race relations
in Oakland in the post Oscar Grant era and
also a legacy of Jerry Brown's housing policy
in Oakland and all these various issues of
gentrification in Oakland today.
And talking with him really challenged where
I stand on various things.
And it was very interesting interviewing him
because we've known each other since high
school.
And he's been working as a community organizer
in East Oakland, but he also has a thriving
business and he performs quite a bit with
his hip-hop and spoken word.
And so, that was--.
If you're gonna read one interview, it would
be the Ise Lyfe one.
And this is K Flay.
Another musician.
This is Kid Beyond, who is a beat boxer.
So, he, that was one of the most entertaining
interviews I did.
And unfortunately, the text version really
doesn't do him justice because he did about
ten different impersonations during the interview.
He actually can do a spot-on impersonation
of Barack Obama.
And so, I had him do "Hey, you're listening
to the DJ Matt Werner show on Fresh Air: The
Alternative, University of Edinburgh student
radio."
But he said the call line in Obama's voice.
And for a couple weeks after, at school, at
the University of Edinburgh, people were wondering
like, "How did you get Barack Obama to do
the voice over on your show?"
Or, "How did you manipulate his speeches to
say DJ Matt Werner and Fresh Air: The Alternative?"
So, yeah.
He's a very talented guy.
And for him, unfortunately, the text version,
it's good but it really doesn't do this range,
this vocal talent that he has justice.
And so, that one, I do have podcasts of most
of the interviews on my website.
Matts writing dot com.
And then this is MC Lars, who his trademark
is wearing an Oakland A's starter cap.
So, yeah.
He's also from Oakland.
And this was Saul Williams, a spoken word
artist.
And the reason I interviewed him is that he's
from Philadelphia.
He's not from Oakland, but he's had a real
big impact on the style of spoken word that
a lot of the artists I interviewed.
So, I thought he would be a good edition to
have in the book.
And then, I also interviewed Talib Kweli,
who is from Brooklyn, New York.
And then, he also has had a big influence
on the style of this progressive hip-hop that
a number of the artists I interviewed shared.
So, that's why I included him in the collection.
And then this is Victor Vazquez aka Kool AD.
He's from this band called Das Racist.
And they have this very interesting style
of post-modern hip-hop.
And for him, I went to, basically I went to
grade school with him in Alameda.
And I had been reading stuff about him saying,
well basically, articles had called him like
a Brooklyn artist and then some had said he's
from Hunter's Point, San Francisco.
But then I wanted to set the record straight,
like, "No, he's from Oakland and Alameda."
So, to claim that East Bay.
So, I included him in the collection as well.
So, that's the conclusion of the overview
of who I interviewed and a little bit of background
about the book.
And if you guys would like, we have a microphone
right there.
You can come up and ask some questions.
>>Male #1: Is this?
I'm curious how you feel about the popularization
of First Friday slash Art Murmur in Oakland
and the notoriety that's bringing to especially
the visual arts scene of Oakland.
>>Matt: So, you're question is how do I feel
about the popularization of the First Friday
Art Murmur in Oakland?
>>Male #1: Mm-hmm.
>>Matt: Well, I think it's a very interesting
event.
I've been going there every month since November
of 2011, I've been attending.
And I've written a number of pieces for Oakland
Local--the local news site--recapping what's
happened at this month's Art Murmur.
And for those of you who aren't familiar with
it, the first Friday of each month in Oakland
in this Northgate-Waverly district, it's a
little bit outside of the downtown, right
before you hit the Broadway auto row.
There's now 25 galleries and mixed-use spaces
that open up and thousands of people come
out in downtown Oakland between 6 to 10 PM
each month.
And it's really an amazing event where there's
yeah, all these artists in the galleries themselves,
but then there's so many different street
performers, street vendors.
I was actually selling my book the last couple
of months on the street.
And people make their own jewelry.
It's very interesting event.
But what's interesting is some of the people
I interviewed in the book have mixed feelings
about it.
I know Chinaka Hodge, she posted on Facebook
a while back where she was jogging through
I guess that area of Oakland wearing a shirt
that said "Kill a Hipster, Save Your Hood."
[laughter]
And she was getting some kind of nasty looks
or shocked looks.
And then, I know Ise Lyfe, his real name is
Isaac Brown.
He's been highly critical of some of Jerry
Brown's 10K plan, which a lot of people feel
was the precursor to this wave of artists.
So, there are some in Oakland who argue that
turning these auto repair shops into these
art galleries is actually really rising rents
and pushing people out of this area of Oakland.
And I think that may be a valid argument.
I haven't really researched it too much.
But the feeling of Art Murmur, 'cause I've
written now a few pieces on this, and I interviewed
one woman a couple months back who, and I
asked about the start of Art Murmur and what
she thinks of it now.
And she said when it first started up about
five or six years ago, it was a lot of these
art students from California Academy of the
Arts and it had this real hipster vibe.
And she called it like a 'too cool for school'
thing.
It's people come out on their track bikes
with the skinny jeans, drinking their Pabst
Blue Ribbon, smoking their skinny cigarettes.
And it had this elitest-like, artsy vibe.
But in the last like, six months though, I
felt that Art Murmur has become very democratic
in that there's people from all areas of Oakland,
all walks of life, and they're there, a lot
of people are there on the street just trying
to make an extra buck, you know, selling tamales,
things like that.
And so, for me, I'd say overall it's a positive
thing because I'd love to see Oakland get
known for its art, its music, its local culture,
get this recognition as opposed to just people
fixating on the violence in Oakland, which
is present.
I'm not going to gloss over that.
But it's not the only thing happening in Oakland.
>>Male #1: Thanks.
[pause]
>>Male #2: You mentioned you were tear gassed.
I'm assuming that was Occupy Oakland and not
at a party.
But the, as somebody who was also there, I'm
wondering what are your thoughts and what
are the artists thoughts on Occupy Movement,
its surgeance and its vibrance in popular
media?
>>Matt: So, the Occupy Oakland question.
>>Male #2: Of course.
>>Matt: I was hoping someone wouldn't ask
my thoughts and opinions of it.
I'm torn.
It's very complicated.
It was last October.
It was in late October.
There was the police crackdown on Occupy Oakland
where they came in and raided the camp.
And then, the police shot off the tear gas
and then there was a veteran was shot in the
head by one of those tear gas canisters--Scott
Olsen.
And it was very tense moment.
And during the week, I live here in Mountain
View, close to the office.
And then on weekends, I go back to Oakland.
And my housemates, who don't really understand
Oakland, said, "Oh, it's just people in Oakland
are angry again.
Oh, it's just riots again in Oakland."
And I became insulted.
I was like, "How dare you just dismissively
say 'Oh, it's just, that's what people do
in Oakland on weekends.
They go out and riot.'"
And then the police need to go and control
them.
And I felt I had a lot of friends naive comments
about Occupy Oakland, so I was like, well
I wanna go in and check it out.
So, I went in just a couple days after that
incident where Scott Olsen was shot and I
went into the general assembly.
And this was October 28th, 2011.
And I wrote a piece on it for Oakland Local
and it was actually made into a play that
Theater Pub did in January of this year.
And it was just called "My Visit to Occupy
Oakland."
And I felt that I wasn't really part of the
movement, but I was there more from a sociological
or cultural anthropologist perspective, there
trying to understand what's going on because
it's like I was knee-deep working on this
book on Oakland and that was by far the biggest
news happening in Oakland.
So I wanted to be there on the ground, find
out what was happening.
And then, fast forward to, I believe it was
January 28th of this year.
There was a similar type of protest and crackdown,
except I didn't know about it.
I was researching for my book.
I was at the Oakland Main Library and then
I was cycling over to the Oakland Museum of
California, right there on the lake.
And it just happened to be that right on,
I think it was 10th Street, all of a sudden
when I'm coming up, I see these road flares
and I smell this really powerful smell.
And I think it's just road flares and stuff.
And I see all these cop cars and unmarked
vehicles and then these protesters in those
plastic handcuffs.
And the crowd had just been dispersed.
And so I'm there and then I stop my bike and
I hop down and there's this photographer there.
I'm like, "What just happened?"
And then I'm like, "Is that pepper spray in
the air?"
And then he's like, "No, that's tear gas.
They just shot it off."
And I was like, "Oh, like I need to get out
of here."
So, I felt that people just even living in
downtown Oakland or passing through there
at any point like in the last six months,
you would inadvertently be part of Occupy
or it would affect you in some way.
And then, but as far as firmly coming down
and saying like, is Occupy Oakland good or
is it bad?
I'd have to say somewhere in-between because
now there's all these different factions of
it that I don't fully understand like what
the goals of the Black Bloc are.
And it's this group of anarchists and but
yeah.
I don't really know too much more about them
to really make a informed comment.
[pause]
>>Male #3: So, Oakland has been on the frontlines
of the medicinal marijuana issue and recent
crackdowns of the Oaksterdam back in effect.
Just wondering what your feelings were about
that and if you see any changes, if your interviews
referenced it.
It's been, like it or not, it's been a big
part of the local economy.
Not a lot of people are aware of that.
But it does actually affect a lot more people's
lives than you would imagine even not the
people who directly are involved with it.
>>Matt: Yeah.
So, at the First Friday Art Murmur, just happened
a few days ago.
Oaksterdam actually had quite a big presence.
There was their mascot was there dressed as
a giant bong.
And then they had people carrying the actual
marijuana plants at their table.
But with Oaksterdam and the crackdown, it
didn't come up in the book.
The book was more on how did the shooting
of Oscar Grant by the BART police officer
really change things in Oakland.
And the marijuana policy of Oakland didn't
really come up.
But I know that is definitely one of like
the top five issues in Oakland today because
it is a big tax revenue generator.
And it actually has quite a bit of political
support in Oakland.
I went to a Rebecca Kaplan fundraiser a few
weeks back and she openly supported Oaksterdam
and the medicinal marijuana places in Oakland.
And a lot of the council members are very
supportive of it and they were very angry
that the Feds came in and cracked down, whereas
local law and state law allow it.
So, it's gonna be a very interesting issue
to see how that plays out with local and state
politics versus federal politics.
But I'm not really up on those set of debates.
OK.
Thank you guys for coming out.
And then I also have some photos from the
book and you can also purchase books over
here for 15 dollars.
OK, thank you.
[applause]